>> Now if you promise to stay away from the Leafy Greens like Kale
or Spinach. I think this dose of Warfarin will be just right for you
[SOUND].
>> Thanks Doc.
>> No problem.
>> Knowing your Genotype for the VKORC1 or
CYP2C9 Allele could be really important information to share
with your doctor. So, he or she can prescribe
the right dose of Warfarin that maximizes the Efficacy
and minimizes the Toxicity. Now even if you don't
know this genetic information beforehand there are ways of
measuring your reaction to a particular dose of a
drug like Warfarin after you've started treatment. But wouldn't
it be nice to know this genetic information in
advance? So let's see if you can put all
this knowledge together that we've learned about in this
lesson and come up with the right prescription. You
can prove to me that you understand what the right prescription would be if you
can tell me what combination of the following possibilities could result in
maximum warfarin toxicity. Remember that, warfarin toxicity means too
much warfarin. To help you out I put down here the pathway. Warfarin blocks
Blood Clotting, if it blocks blood clotting too much it actually causes bleeding
or hemorrhaging. Its mechanism of action is
by blocking VKORC1. Which promotes Vitamin K
recycling. Which leads to blood clotting and
CYP2C9 metabolizes warfarin. So it effectively inhibits
the activity of warfarin. For each of
these three possible categories here. I want you
to tell me which total combination of
these three things would result in maximum warfarin
toxicity? And once you do that I want you to describe for me why you
think that is. Why the particular combination
you've selected you think is the right answer.